il y a une seule denberg 7 entretenu
avec la presse allemande il est
actuellement en visite à Berlin sur ce
ce dossier suédois il réagit également
ce matin à la requête formulée par
plusieurs États européens de livrer des
armes lourdes à l'Ukraine et bien le
patron de l'OTAN se dit ce matin
confiant sur cette livraison prochaine
une solution sera bientôt trouvée
estime-t-il aujourd'hui Varsovie a
officiellement formulé tout à l'heure à
Berlin une demande d'autorisation le
livret des léopards 2 à Kiev pour le
moment l'Allemagne n'a pas encore donné
son feu vert vous le savez mais au vu
des récentes déclarations on sent quand
même que les lignes sont peut-être en
train de bouger on va retrouver à ce
propos Nick Spicer qui est notre
correspondant à Berlin bonjour Nick le
ministre allemand de la Défense vient de
nouveau s'exprimer ce matin il estime
que les alliés peuvent commencer dit-il
à former les Ukrainiens à utiliser des
chars léopard expliquez-nous
et bien pour le citer il a dit qu'il
encourageait à des alliés qui
disposaient de Charles léopard 2 a
commencé à former des soldats
Ukrainiens sur ces chars or il faut
souligner que le ministre de défense
ukrainien a annoncé vendredi que les
soldats Ukrainiens allaient déjà partir
en Ukraine pour suivre ses formations
donc on a vraiment l'impression que les
Allemands essaient de donner
l'impression d'un mouvement qui est
difficile à mesurer étant donné qu'une
décision les décisions n'ont pas été
prises sur les des deux questions
principales c'est
ça consiste à savoir si l'Allemagne va
autoriser la réexportation de Charles
léopard 2 de pays qui en possèdent et si
l'Allemagne va elle-même exporter ses
chars en Ukraine on a vraiment
l'impression ces derniers jours
d'une incapacité de décider vendredi
dernier il y avait cette réunion vous
rappeler des 14 pays donateurs de
d'armes en Ukraine en Allemagne on
pensait allez avoir une décision de la
part des Allemands or il n'y a pas eu de
décision
dimanche dernier le la ministre des
Affaires étrangères allemandes a déclaré
à la télévision française et je tiens à
souligner qu'une ce serait possible
d'envisager une exportation une
exportation de ses chats or de lendemain
lundi hier c'est-à-dire le ministre le
porte-parole de chancelier ola shots qui
prend la décision finale donc qui est le
seul autorisé à se prononcer là-dessus
dit que en fait une décision n'avait pas
été prise donc il faut considérer un peu
ce qui se passe ici à Berlin c'est il y
a énormément de pression de la part des
alliés qui demandent à l'Allemagne de
faire un geste d'autoriser au moins
l'exportation des chars des pays qui
sont volontaires dans ce domaine et que
voilà
même à l'intérieur de la coalition au
gouvernementale il y a des tensions avec
les vers qui sont pour l'exportation qui
se prononce pour pour au moins une
autorisation de séchage et quand on
considère l'opposition et des critiques
plus de toutes parts membres de la
partie chrétien démocrate a dit que
l'Allemagne donnait une très mauvaise
image à l'international une image
d'obstination et de coordises merci
mes soeurs en direct de Berlin après ces
dernières déclarations à un autre avoir
réagi c'est le Kremlin